Shadow is complicated I got into this
industry when I was 18 about to turn 19
and I just have always loved sex and
being a sexual person okay stop oh my
God first of all why am I watching this
with my mom I don't know I don't know I
don't know what's wrong with you I think
I've been far too nice to you that's the
problem anyway
if you're still saying I was 18 about to
turn 19 you're too young to be doing
sexy things on tape because like that's
like a six-year-old you ask them how old
are you six and a half they can't just
say six or they'll say six and three
quarters I'm excited about the next
level that's facts like 18 about to turn
19. okay pumpkin go back to Daddy and oh
my God oh my God what that oh that's the
problem there was no Daddy this is going
to make a lot of really good Clips this
video I gotta say that for all you
Clippers make sure you're clipping this
up gonna get views on your Tick Tock
accounts I got into this industry when I
was 18 years old I'm really horny I was
18 whenever I first got into sex work
what why do you decide to then just go
on video and do it like you're a good
looking girl just go be a hoe why do you
gotta film it for the whole world am I
missing something I don't know let's
let's find out I was a
was eight got into sex work and I
originally started out as a stripper
I've been making nude content since I
was 18. I submitted when I was 18. I
can't get in but that didn't stop me I
ended up doing suicide girls that
transition into only fans what do you
think is the direct correlation how are
they all starting at 18 like you don't
even give it you don't even give
anything a chance you don't even give
life a chance
um the the initial it's crazy The
Stereotype is there are daddy issues
yeah you know either bad daddy or
missing Daddy but that is not to say
that a a woman raising a daughter
without a father this is gonna that's
this is how she's gonna grow up I mean
this is I think is the exception not the
rule you could have daddy issues and
still not grow up to do this at 18 to me
to over sexualize yourself to this
extent is kind of just as gonna be just
as damaging to to a girl's future as it
as changing her gender you know I mean
there's there's going to be trauma after
this and there is going to come a time
when she wants to be you know in her
late 20s 30 already like just go back to
anonymity and be a mom and then they're
stuck with her years and years of
footage of her no don't even fill in the
blank you know on the internet like
that's sad I think that's sad and I
think that like any like any 18 year old
you can't see the future you can't see
it doesn't matter how many times an
adult tells you the things you do now
are going to affect your future right we
always say that decisions you make today
will affect your tomorrow and all the
whatever phrases we have you can't see
it when you're that age it almost should
be like you have to be 25 to be a sex
worker or a porn star yeah the fact that
it's 18 like what what year are we in
your brain is not developed that's 2005.
2005 people can do that now like that's
horrible like these are little babies
these are like just a few months ago
this girl was in a prom dress yeah no
that's horrible you know and now she's
doing God knows what you know fake
auditions or whatever the hell kind of
you know how do you know naughty nurse I
don't know what the hell they do Haram
it's really sad because their brains
aren't developed and she's gonna they're
gonna really be damaged yeah no that's
horrible well when I was 18
making non-new
nude putting up my own videos flipping
off the camera telling losers to pay me
money and that was really really fun
then I met a man who brought out the
submissive side in me I convinced him to
ditch his job and move to Vegas and do
porn with me and that's what we do now
I'm not trying to be the one to like
make fun of looks too but it is really
fascinating how like you can go into
this industry as like even a not so good
looking girl and still make a killing
yeah yeah not even [ __ ] on her I'm
just saying in general but no like some
are in my opinion prettier than others
but yeah like yeah right even if you're
a fat girl like there's there's a market
for it honestly the fat girl Market is
probably bigger than the hot dude Market
which is insane to think about like the
top dude Market yeah that's wild to
think about but you know equality 18
when I got into this industry
and I
yeah
figured I
did I link a little bit more I just
don't understand like how these girls
get talked into stripping they could
just go waitress somewhere and you know
make 500 bucks a night if you're in a
good restaurant bartend yeah bartend and
well you're you know at least waitress
you can't bartend when until you're 21
in many places but still go waitress go
bartend do without some things and and
you don't have you know you don't have
this constant barrage of people treating
you and looking down on you and I'm
sorry and then they're they'll be
feminists who say how dare you look down
on them I feel sorry for them because
they're just so far from the light it
it's it's sad to me I don't I would like
to hear a little bit of a longer
interview with one of these girls to see
if this goes any deeper let's let's
super sad super sad so stripping and
only fans while there's like still in
the same Community they're both in sex
work stripping has the benefit of having
instant cash you can get the money that
night and you know like you get to have
real personal interaction to talk to
people face to face interacting with
people face to face Some people prefer
being behind a camera it's just your own
personal preference
what was your body count before you
entered this program before I entered
this profession take a guess take a
guess I'm sorry what do you think like
if you're going in at 18 what do you
think under over 25 oh under it's got to
be under come on my body count was in
the 50s I don't know exactly that is
crazy in the 50s
oh my God
she's talking about her High School
junior high and high school career so if
she had been passed around through her
entire town that much at that point she
doesn't even probably has a hard time
having any other identity but being a
sex object because that's like that's a
lot of time like that's a lot of time
that's a lot of herpes and crabs and and
syphilis sorry that's crazy that's just
crazy
she's a beautiful girl she's beautiful
look at that face it's gorgeous look at
her skin my body count was 11 entering
this profession I hit 100 before I did
porn so when I was a stripper I had some
friends when I hit 50 they threw me a
halfway hoe party at the strip club
that's a full hole party
I was thinking the same thing 50 you're
throwing the halfway party what do you
what planet do you live on that they're
throwing parties for them for themselves
like what is going on what is happening
I am I did not think I was a nun prude
living under a rock but I clearly am I
was like well what's next I want to
kidnap them all
kind I don't know wait don't use that I
don't know my body count
has any of your family seen your films
and if so what do they think they have
seen my films they've seen lots of
photos as well
um they are not too happy with me
they've seen your films that's horrible
you were there someone's daughter
someone's niece and they had to see that
oh my God I'm so grateful none of the
people the people in my family have ever
done that that's just yeah that's just
terrible that's just horrible my God
even like a cousin like no like no no no
no no no none that we know of Abdul get
the rocks
they're coming around and supporting me
now so my sister okay they're supporting
my videos and she has yo not trying to
be that guy but like
what's up with that it's
she'll say it's for you know pleasure or
something but I it's really that's crazy
I don't like the I don't like that to
say
not very good ones
part of my family disowned me but we're
currently working on rebuilding the
relationship you know what the craziest
thing too is like when you look at all
like the biggest stars they all regret
it like they all say it's their biggest
mistake that they ever made was getting
into this like for the amount of Fame
and even if you don't get that famous
like the reputation it leaves you it's
just never worth it like it's never
worth it there's so many better things
you can do you can go be a gold digger
you're hot all of you guys are hot
except for a few of you you can get a
good guy get one sugar down get a bang
on Instagram start a tick tock buy my
course I'll help you with your Tick Tock
marketing go viral and just open your
DMs that's it you don't have to go
posting only fans this makes only fans
though seem like like pornography and
the filming and the the filth oh my God
makes only fans seem like church oh yeah
no not even in the same yeah 100 has
your career choice ever affected your
romantic relationship and the crazy
thing about only fans is you're not even
talking to girls you're talking to a
dude it's like it's Philip it's Filipino
dudes who are getting paid two dollars
an hour with an agency to sit there and
chat that's what they were trained to do
I know this stuff I was thinking about
starting one and then I was like please
don't no exactly I was thinking about it
and I was like I'm too good at Tick Tock
I'm gonna be all over everyone's feed
and I was like I don't want to be
spreading that like there's no like I
would just feel bad if I'm just like
like every time I see that on my feet
I'm like oh this is horrible there's no
honor in it there's nothing good no and
I know you know that it's not your jam
just yet but I know that you've also
been exploring you know Christianity and
Islam and and if there's a greater
purpose and a greater better way to live
the way God wants me doing that and if
yeah you're going to be living by God's
laws this is this is just too far out
the box I'm already making I'm already
watching this with my mom I'm at like
the end already he's already just kicked
us down to Hell like second or third
level of Health at this point look at
this girl though she's beautiful I just
don't care definitely I I mean it's hard
for people to conceptualize the idea of
dating somebody who has sex with other
people do you think people can learn to
be good lovers from watching porn I
think people could definitely improve as
lovers in general and I do think that
porn could give you a lot of food for
thought but it's like you're not going
to become a great basketball player by
watching basketball you're going to
become a great basketball player by
playing basketball what does he mean by
that well the question was can people
improve their skills in bed by watching
porn
so I I think I give you some good food
for thought but it's definitely not
gonna like teach you everything there is
to know and also there's a lot of stuff
we do on camera in porn that is not
really applicable to real life sex
there's a lot of like positions that you
might be doing just because it looks
good for the camera I hate this in
reality it's just not it's not really
what any girl is trying to do in real
life would you ever date a guy who
bought only fans content every week the
same Creator or would you consider that
cheating and ask him I'm like dude how
is this on YouTube Alex blurred this
girl because just tell me you know what
I mean like and then if it like
continued despite the fact that I'm like
offering all this you know I would I
would probably dump him let me tell you
something guys what you jerk off to is
like the last person you killed you keep
that [ __ ] secret you got no reason to
go spilling the beans to your girl
you're giving her ammunition that she
does not need she's gonna find [ __ ] to
fight with you over no matter what don't
tell her who you're jerking off to or
whatever you know clear clear your cash
clear your history skip open up an
anonymous browser tab memorize your
password just my advice do sex workers
prefer to date other sex workers not all
but I think that most do yeah some do I
will not and won't why not
it's weird
do you have any particular reason I mean
um I just like I feel like it's too
based off of content Sex and Money I
like my relationships be real
is there a wage Gap in the adult
industry
yeah I think men are like significantly
underpaid and I think they work some men
really hard I think oh wow that was
definitely an interesting take you said
they work the men really hard they don't
get paid enough interesting it's been
really hard I think there's a lot more
women than men doing porn porn needs
more men I hope there's more male talent
that gets involved in Industry why do
you rarely hear complaints about female
porn stars making more money than male
stars
um that's a really good question
I don't know to me all that's doing is
like flattening income amongst people
right like an incoming inequality is a
bad thing I think that this is one of
the only Industries where a woman will
most times make more money than a man
because there's a greater demand because
the women's soccer team makes less than
the men because nobody buys tickets the
women are the draw here the woman's the
star no one's watching for the dude I
mean you know but there's is a
tremendous gay porn industry so there
are yeah but that's horny dudes like
that's not girls watching it it's like
like the whole porn industry is built
from dudes watching it it's not from
girls watching it yeah some girls do
once in a while but like let's just be
real yeah this is it's not it's not even
on the same it's like comparing like
your local Middle School basketball team
the attendance there to the NBA yeah
it's it's not even the same thing yeah I
think
is where a woman will
win will be paid what they deserve I
also am so happy that women are finally
put in a position where they can they
can earn more than the man
even though I think the men should earn
more I'm really happy that women have an
industry where they dominate because
there's not a lot of Industries where
women dominate so if we have more people
making you're proud that the industry
that you dominate is the sex filming
industry that's what you're proud about
that just shows I'm getting canceled
that just shows what your value like
where your value is it's in the it's in
your looks it's horrible this is like
this is just disgusting I I like I
actually wish I had more to say because
I'm just sitting here shaking my head I
can't even think straight thinking about
this this line of thinking oh this is
hard and what goes on here and how sad
it is that these girls are just
constantly talked to like howling them
you know how important they are and how
great they are and well you should do
this and you can do this and you're
going to get rich and I'll make you
famous baby and all this and they're
gonna have you know evidence of horrible
[ __ ] that they've done and I look at I
look back on when I was from you know it
could say 18 to 22 college Years how
stupid I was I wasn't doing anything
like this of course but like it's a
complete idiot you know I've had some
made some good decisions and and but but
overall I wasn't able to really think
clearly about my life and my future and
most people aren't at that age and these
girls clearly aren't and they're making
decisions that you know but my decisions
my bad decisions that I made you know
drinking or you know maybe getting in a
dangerous situation which usually also
involved alcohol you know they're not
still with me today and they're not
certainly not all over the Internet is
there an age guy
some men are a lot older than the woman
I'm I think you can be successful at any
age I know lots of MILFs lots of
grandmas doing porn I want to do porn
forever I'm only 22 but I'm ready
you guys will take me that she wants to
do porn forever what part yeah that
whole thing that there's a lot of MILFs
and grannies that's because there's some
there's there's listen there's something
for everybody people have are attracted
to all kinds of different things no I I
mean I know like we just you know
there's a market for the fact like there
could be a [ __ ] Cyclops lady out
there and she's making money because
somebody's dying to bang a cyclops
there's midgets people like midgets God
that's a whole thing oh I know me yeah
well
yeah sometimes it's a joke nah never
mind I know then we're gonna be my
friend the midgets protesting no yeah
you just sometimes like if your friend
wasn't looking he'd put some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] on his phone and when he opens it
it's like midgets banging Haram I'm
sorry that's horrible in the average
lifespan of a porn star is four years
lifespan of a porn star is about six
months at what age do most porn stars
leave the profession I don't know I've
seen some pretty seasoned looking women
around here so I was 48 when I started
chatterbaiting and I was 50 when I did
my first mainstream porn scene what was
your body count before you entered this
profession four
oh my God what how do you even start
that late am I tripping like like what
the hell happens like life is a series
of events like you say something there's
an event you you move something there's
that has an effect there's a ripple on
everything everything leads to something
yes I don't know so what happened who'd
she meet that was like you should do
this how much was she making that's what
I want to know was she making like a
gajillion dollars at 48 did she just get
divorced and like she hated her husband
I don't know I mean I would like to hear
that story
I would be working at Target oh she'd be
a botanist the other one's gonna be an
astronaut I'm not doing porn what other
profession would you be doing I'd be a
botanist an astronaut
no [ __ ] way this chick said she'd be
an astronaut nothing stopped you from
being an astronaut you could have done
it you could have studied you could have
taken the steps to become an astronaut
but you said [ __ ] it no she doesn't want
to be an astronaut if you wanted to be
an astronaut you could have become an
astronaut she just wants to give [ __ ]
jobs in space I mean not you you ruined
that that's not why are you working at
Target
at least she was honest so I got laid
off during covid I used to be a be a
college professor
if you're any of my former students
conservational biologist and I would
help save tigers from Extinction my
dream all right these are all like
ridiculous occupations this is like when
you ask an 8th grader what he wants to
be okay I also need to know
um why can't you be both like how many
are you eight out eight hours a day
doing the deed on camera like how much
time could this really take that you
can't also study botany honestly if
anything it's like one of those
professions where you could make a lot
of money for not a lot of time and then
pursue what you really wanted if you
were gonna be smart about it you could
have done those other things you could
have you could have gone and studied
flowers and whatever and then you know
your Friday night was taken up save
tigers from Extinction this lady my
dream job is no job
I would probably be doing marketing and
graphic design and basically everything
I'm doing right now just not being
important okay is there a difference
between a great male versus female porn
star and that's uh that's a tough
question because I don't really what do
you think this guy's job is here like
what do you like he has a purpose for
being here he has a little he has this
thing on
he has a purpose what does he do
look at other people
um I um to be a great performer I think
you do need to be a great person
um respecting people's boundaries but
you also what she's so cute like she's
like childlike cute almost if she didn't
have the thing in her nose and you know
like she looks like a child to me this
lady's tripping too I mean respect
boundaries and be a good person I mean
let's say you're a good actor how like
what does any of that have to do with
being an actor you're an actor all
you're doing I'm not even gonna get it
no explain I don't know what you're
getting at what is being a good person
have anything to do with what you do
even the boundaries you're you're told
what to do it doesn't matter if you're
comfortable with if the other person's
like comfortable with or not it's like
the director telling you what to do if
you don't want to do it someone else
will do it right so like what is that
you have to be a good person I'm sure
the difference is that
the Stars
[Music]
on a male porn stars have to actually
perform I think a great male porn star
focuses on the females
um and a great female porn star focuses
on the fans and also interacting with
the camera and like knowing their angles
uh yeah does porn appeal to women and if
so if they marketed differently it does
appeal to women and it has to be bro is
bro was checking something out
look at this it does appeal to be hot
and it has to be marketed differently it
has to be more of a sense oh he's just
like
oh my God his eyes are on fire I didn't
even hear it
I think most porn is marketed to men
that's just true
I Market my porn primarily to men why
are men more likely to consume porn
while women are more likely to consume
romance novels because women are more
mentally stimulated I think some women
like more of the kinky stuff and then
there's also porn that's more called
ethical porn that is made that is a
little more soft and sensual and more
about the story and the connection which
can lead you to have like more of an
emotional experience than just a
physical that's so sad to Market porn
specifically to women implies that
there's something about being a woman
that we all have in common and that
by virtue of of that I'm supposed to
enjoy a certain kind of sex and a
certain kind of porn and I think that's
horseshit I think well all women are
very different I think and I think men
are a little bit more you know
standard people use the phrase I think
very liberally you know think you're not
there you just be just no thinking going
on you just there like look at these two
guys over here like off of her shoulder
like some like like I hope your wives
don't see this they're just like there
for a technology
and they're like let's go to that that
would be hilarious if you're like
getting lunch and you're like oh the
Porn Convention let's pop in let's pop
in see what goes on site but my favorite
porn category bro's got his beer he's
just like chilling as the rise in of
only fans affected the adult industry
and if so how
I personally think that it has affected
it for the better because more people
more women especially get to be in
charge of their own content
um I think before when they were just
pornhouses and people were under
contracts and things like that there
were large Cuts being taken and now you
get to be a little bit more in control
of your own image putting your own
content out there it has affected it and
negatively because everybody believes
they're a porn star now they don't have
any idea what kind of work it takes to
actually make a scene
what was your most embarrassing moment
caught on camera oh my God I don't know
if I can say that on your YouTube
channel I don't want your video to get
flagged the most embarrassing moment
caught on film my most embarrassing
moment caught on camera back in the days
when you were allowed to stick objects
inside of you my most embarrassing
moment caught on film this one's a
[ __ ] good one I'm telling you right
now like I have never told this story in
an interview and I'm kind of nervous too
because it's vile if you don't like scat
get out of this like don't watch this I
don't know what that is what was your
most embarrassing moment caught on
camera
yeah I'm good I'm I'm all set there why
did you make me watch that yeah that was
horrible
no turning that off no what's the end of
this let's just watch that was it oh
okay he said more on Rumble I'm not
doing that we're not nope we're not
doing that all right thank you guys so
much for watching this was a horrible to
make yeah make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfast and
if you wanna and if you know any young
women that are doing this that are in
this world just
talk to them about their value and talk
to them about the bazillion other
options they have for making a living
and and also still being beautiful and
sexy if that's important to them but
this this is no way this is just a life
of trauma and regret
oh my God
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]